gonna get better your your
ability to deal with it gets better it's
not like it just becomes easier you
become stronger so you just gotta test
it yeah any available ability yeah
yes exactly and we got the bob out i
like this
okay this is another character he's been
playing recently
um and getting good results with his
what the humpty bob the outfit okay i
actually hate this outfit bro i hate
this yeah
he that's all he wears
500 milligrams of trend
always where's the humpty bob the outfit
guaranteed oh my god
all right
a little earlier too right oh nice yeah
this is big damage oh no didn't get the
full connection right there just a
little low
wow
tries to go back in
yeah those strings especially coming
from bob if you don't know how many hits
in it a lot of times they gonna come
back around and track you so a guy
caught sidestepping a little bit with
that one yeah
yeah mid-stream that just realigned on
you and popped you for it there it is no
goes for the punishable version no good
oh denied
no break
wow
okay this is gonna be some serious
damage
oh boy
ah that's gonna be tough to get out of
fight
all right okay so you can take the lead
yeah one round a piece i like the like i
like the pace that they're both playing
at right now gets the tackle
going back to the abuser i liked it
okay big big folks this time gets the
counter yeah
no big combos just chip
look at the damage wow he gets the hit
okay full combo with the blue stuff
you get the wall there it is
you shine no good
he's gonna get the sweep no it goes to
the regular low okay
and there it is just to close out
round four
why take big risks
yeah back to the government catch people
like oh yeah while they're trying to
move especially against the wall
okay
applying some pressure oop right back at
him
yeah once he gets like you know as i've
i've been saying this for years bobby is
a true son of heihachi not lars he's got
the toolkit okay he's a true mishima he
went to vegas
and apparently bob didn't stay in vegas
he left and now here he is dude
so hey stuff happens
yo he's playing this i like the pace
that he's playing at right now yeah
damn okay to the wire to the wire
but yeah once um bob goes full machine
mode weibo goes into the the low stress
he hasn't really got into that play yet
he's very held back trying to get that
counter here to get a proper launch and
then he gets a lot harder
versus alyssa because like and this is
what you mentioned like she can be a lot
more aggressive like you see right there
even though like bob has some of the
better pokes in it in the game that
crouch dash won a lot of strings that
you have to respect alisa is one of
those characters that we've already
mentioned the offense goes up a lot
higher because they've made her a more
aggressive character this season
especially with like chainsaw stance and
just being able to kind of harass any
character that she wants to at this
point not so much the the leroys or the
focker rounds because of the strings uh
characters with like quick back ones and
stuff like that they can you know make
you control that up close counter hit
game but a lot of the other characters
they really have to respect the spacing
that elisa puts on you like and the
piece that she plays at
yeah yeah it's become a high tempo
character and
if you're not willing to like be feel
comfortable under that fire you just get
beaten up it's really stressful
like you gotta you know
get around it and it's hard to get
around i was gonna like just when i
realized with all the lateral movement
which is insane she's always gritted up
on you you can't really sneak around her
in any way she can always catch up with
you yeah because she has a very very
very very tragic
she has a lot of great track and
movement her side step is really good as
well so you have to respect it yeah and
if you try to fight that little scramble
um that's when she really starts to get
to hit you with a lot of those tracking
moves standing for being one of them
yeah a lot of people always ask why her
rage drive hits so much is because
people try to do quick side steps to get
away from those pokes yes
you're one time and then it's like well
i just lost the round because of it and
a lot of elise's they paced around
to see if you're going to get hit by
those kinds of things but here we go
game number two wowser and 500 for 500
with the big down back four and gets the
wall but didn't get the shoulder
there we go no break getting the wall
pressure
you can poke him in the corner and gets
the warp splat into a nicely aligned
combo bringing him to another wall maybe
no good okay there it is
bounce into break let's see oh my god
and in the rain close it up
no i don't think so but god damn is in a
good position
and there it is right at the corner but
your account get away from losing
that was so slick
okay okay that's wowza for you dude
yeah okay all right oh he actually just
hit me with the wowza because i
definitely was surprised i was like bro
you're about to get hit something crazy
oh yeah
oh nice
okay
trying to keep
trying to get in there but um
500 mils always just out poking him
back
wall break and steal the tail spin on
top of it oh oh wow
wrong combo quick tech on the wall
while they're in trouble
rage is on the side oh wow gets out of
there wow that was acrobatic right there
damn okay let's see if he's gonna get a
mid there you go
okay uh-oh
up it's it's it's the final round music
of g corp night time yeah you know it is
what it is
look it's got some good parts man that
one little three second stint on this
part of the song i'm actually a fan
yeah yeah
it's a little bit of a pinch of sugar in
the medicine if you know what i mean
like it is
it's the good ass tekken part of the
song oh the sprinkler
oh my god oh okay okay he's got grabs
now how's this gonna close
tough but he's still in it okay
that would have been it for wowzer
because right now it is still match
point for himself
oh here we go
[Music]
we're back to the champions league
oh wow quick side step gets them out of
trouble
right after it
cherry's got a beautiful thing
it clean over 500 man the fact that like
wowzer was able to keep the pace under
control even though we saw like 500 m
literally try to like open up the game
like you know what i'm gonna start going
through like these running threes i'm
gonna start trying to open you up by